bene tutti ragazzi e per questo lo video
sono faringeo diciamo sulla state of la
gli ultimi giorni di lazzarotto cosa sia
ma secondo me una torcia era più
economica se troviamo noi stessi con un
desiderio che non sa che in questo mondo
non può soddisfare il resto non lo
potremmo sapere perché sono già mandati
siamo nel 2000 sto male
sembra il kit per chi lo conosce sembra
snake di metalli a queste parla
ludmilla è bello ma io credo che
comunque se questo personaggio si chiama
lazzaro e vive in una casa bello
se ho capito se questo è questo dovesse
suicidata ok quindi sono tornato a casa
alla fine bravo lazzaro impariamo a
vestirci un po meglio va bene che non è
che siamo in te li fai cry 4 come parli
come se [ __ ] metalli via
di roma di chi è chi lavori vabbè
quanti alberi di natale in una casa sola
mio dio
saleh è tutto allegro comunque quel caso
non vedo problematiche tutto tutto alle
grano tutto che funziona milla questo io
michele bello gary
del mero ghiera fabula sole da della era
logico che se l'orologio telefono mi ero
stordito oggi per cazzo sta telefono
pronto
chi sei ludmilla
credevo che saresti arrivato a casa dove
sei tu
che cazzo è
la palla con mille al telefono c'è una
dietro in che fa
ma dov'è the sparita la cosa
ma che cazzo significa ma dov'è la zia
a gatto hai visto qualcosa mica
all'andata non può essere sparita così
com'è andata la zia cos'è
jeu de la rosa per terra
porca [ __ ] cosa succede e salute mica
che erutta ho tirato che è
[ __ ] a sort posso uscire esco
il gatto è sparito dopo prove non mi
toccate il gatto bastardi
fate qualsiasi cosa ma non tocca
tagliato store musicale detto è che è
successo
stava satana dall'altra parte della
porta buffon da ricoh anche con vorrei
proprio a dare ricopro magari tornare
qua non solo è bello leggo romeno è
successo qualcosa di strano
se non ho effettivamente ben capito però
2000 lo sapeva in realtà lupi la non mi
sta perdonando perché non sono andato il
milan mi ha messo dentro satana
trasmette incazzata a fan culo maledetti
ma dove abita altro che richiesta gente
cioè non ho capito ma io più bassa la
musica che palle
maran
ci sono delle
delle robe degli scrosci sui muri graffi
sul muro
è prova il drago dentro
anche chiuso la porta del bagno e si va
beh ma proprio a sfondarla non potresti
fare così con tutte le porte che schifo
io però un paio di volte la userei la
scopa per pulire per uccidere insetti
ecco perché sono poi si crea questo
casino
ciò che a porta brown
non lo so ma nel dubbio io terrei chiuso
sentiamo chiuso devo chiamare la polizia
polizia c'è un verme grosso nel cesso
oddio che schifo che farsi succedendo
mi sta dicendo di mettermi di tenere un
coltello in mano per difendermi ma non
credo che serva qualcosa visto il quale
ha pareggi e più grosso di me
ma vedi che un sacco di persone stanno
un sacco di persone stanno contattando
la polizia perché sto facendo queste
strane non mi possono aiutare bene
grazie
grazie aiuto grazie mi riesco esco fuori
da fuori al cas
non posso riusciremo
mai chiusa non si può aprire
porca [ __ ] che cazzo
la zia e sbagliata l'altro bene il
terremoto possa uscire dalla finestra di
lavorando e cioè la finestra aperta
andiamo alla finestra arrivederci
questo è un portale per l'inferno
sono i libri di harry potter con gli
animati
padre grazie che mi hai ascoltato
dopo esser allucinato a sarà andato che
è uscito uscito sta raccontando che è
uscito è andato dalla sorella era
impaurito per la sua sicurezza intanto
eri tu quello in pericolo non lei ha
quindi veramente uscito ma non riusciva
a sfondare la porta come cazzo è uscito
2000 mi sa che è morta raga incredibile
marinacci perché stava nell'autobus
forse è morta forse no vediamo se
andiamo in giro se troviamo quasi sempre
caso brown ludmilla ma dubito comunque
tutto il pianeta se pianeta tutto
tutta la russia sta andando a [ __ ]
per questa faccenda ci sono gli aerei
che passano incredibile ragazzi ha fatto
benissimo per lo scenario apocalittico
pazzesco ma che idee hanno avuto
veramente qualcuno ha aperto un portale
per l'inferno secondo me v6 stata di
lazzaro
che cosa è successo al suo posto non lo
so ha mai giocato ad un più o meno a
proposito di doom questa roba sarebbe da
prendere io la prenderei fossi in te non
prendiamo i fucili per terra anzi ma che
cazzo stesso cenova bellissimo se va beh
questa non era quella che è la chiesa
che era raffigurato sul sulla bibbia
c'è tutto tutto chiesa per una donna
siamo con la chiesa ancora al centro del
villaggio cosa faccio chiuso una botola
nova questo male
accelero aver cliccato è questo ma chi è
questo c'è uno zio
faccio un terminale per attivare il
carro armato ho scelto ok vado al tutta
la mia canzone c'eran io vado a entrò
nel bunker esso presentare nel bunker
adesso sì
questo che non entrava per questo motivo
tutto chiaro rientriamo nel bunker e
attiviamo il carro armato let's go room
o anche l'icona di cristo sì sì che la
tiriamo al bunker può succedere perfetto
adesso c'è un attivazione ma perché in
russia usando le chiese come copertura
per il bunker ma la mezza faccia la
pensa partito locale armata non è così
difficile realtà
e poi non abbiamo subito dal gala ma fa
niente si no io volevo passare
quarantenni bombardano la falco io
proprio stare qua mi piace proprio
guarda guarda in alto ei
perfetto ci siamo ora che c'è ora che ho
messo la benzina
torniamo nella chiesa questi hanno fatto
un bunker per chi veramente non ho
parole
control
quindi ma perché è un vedere gesù cristo
lo staff sta funzionando almeno non lo
so sono caduto stai qua ma anche secondo
me ti conviene
si sono rivolti
a ce l'ho fatta di kalamata distrutto il
cruiser che non sapeva se
lo sketch up un tasto e non è che ho
fatto ce l'ho fatta arrivare alla
macchina ma ludmilla non l'ho trovata e
lei liudmilla affacci da un cult del
milan e quindi a siamo proprio sono
tornato qua a ma questa non è casa di
mia mamma è casa mia beh vedo che
comunque tu anche agostino stai messo
proprio da dio ma che cazzo ma che cazzo
sto vede c'è il gatto sul vinile io sono
tornato qua dopo che ho visto dei
satana saltarmi in bocca tranquillo è
come se niente fosse quale abbiamo
accesso per le cose ce le facciamo
sempre male io veramente non ho parole
ma come qualche i neuroni aic n 96 a
meno di zero a neuroni
ce l'hanno con le porte chiusi sto gioco
non so per quale cassi motivo sei
entrato tu qua è
sei stupido to cazzi tuoi qui tentato il
fango è
bene bene bene bene questo che te lo
meriti un po effettivamente che se
non lo so
le uscire dalla finestra zio non so come
hai fatto ad entrare a sto punto come
cazzo intanto in quel cazzo sei spider
man non si può entrare proprio ben
rivederci
buongiorno
ludmilla e lei ludmilla
lazzaro sergio
a [ __ ]
è cascato il pavimento una cosa
che cazzo successo è cascato il
pavimento
o merda
the last days of lazarus thank you for
brain bellissimo perché questi ha messo
così a fissare sulla camera dopo che è
successo sta roba guarda tutto figo
ragazzi che sarà the last days of
lazarus gli ultimi giorni di lazzaro che
dire bollettini e folletti né però che i
video vi sia piaciuto come vi piace
schede hackerare e noi ci vediamo come
sempre al prossimo video non so cosa ho
appena giocato ma vabbè tanto ormai un
classico rebella ragazzi
[Musica]